why do you think there is so much
misogyny in the streaming community
and how can you fight it because you've
you've shown
a lot of interest in fighting it trying
to decrease or eliminate misogyny from
your community
I think it's really difficult I think
that eliminating racism is easier than
eliminating misogyny because on the
internet you mean on anywhere because I
think fundamentally I don't think
there's that much difference between
like white people and black people and
brown people and Asian people or
whatever you know we have different
cultures and stuff but at the end of the
day we're all people
but I think there are differences
between men and women like throughout
all of you like all of history and time
and then even today in every culture and
when when real differences do exist it's
harder to account for them in a way that
can we have conversations with each
other without it becoming very gendered
in a negative way right negative way of
generating something like a misogynistic
way of doing it of course
it's unclear to me that it's so
difficult to um
to avoid the negative gendering versus
the positive because there's a lot of
positive to the the tension the dance
between the different genders and so on
maybe in this particular moment in
history it's not but it's not trivial to
me that racism is easier to eliminate
it's an interesting hypothesis just
because there's more biological
difference between men and women that
means it's harder to eliminate but I
don't know if this is true I hear this a
lot I feel like I've read the story but
I need to get a better Source if I
repeat it everywhere but I've heard that
like in the US military for instance
they've gotten exceedingly well they do
an exceedingly good job at getting
different people of different races to
integrate and it's like not a huge
problem once you're through basic
training all the training everything
but for a different Sexes it still
represents a significant problem that
the military hasn't figured out and as
you looked at like what's the military
doing because if you know if something
was solvable like can we sleep for four
hours a night be healthy if we could I
bet the military would know you know so
I kind of look sometimes for them to see
their integration but um it might be
that there are other issues there that
make it yeah it feels like the military
is a very particular country for sure
yeah it could be the actual task at hand
might uh bias the difficulty of the
process potentially yeah there's been a
lot of interesting um talk about like
women integrating into male groups and
how do you do this in a way where
everybody is happy with the outcome and
there's not like issues
um I think Jordan Peterson spoke about
this a little bit and then workplace
culture speaks about this a bit would
you happen to remember I want to say it
was like five or ten years ago there was
a big Tech conference and there were two
guys behind a woman and they made a joke
about like a USB dongle like dongle was
a dick and this woman turned around she
tweeted pictures of them spoke about
like misogyny and then every that blew
up into a huge ordeal that like um yeah
there was this there's this interesting
phenomenon that
and a
less misogynistic and more inclusive
workplace environment
some women might end up feeling worse
because in a more misogynistic
environment you're thinking like okay
that's a woman she doesn't get her humor
I'm going to treat her in a very
indifferent you know very dispassionate
cold way and whatever and then I'm gonna
have my my boys over here
um and then you've got like these
environments where they're a little bit
more warmer and it's like oh cool we're
going to bring this woman into our
environment and we're going to make all
the same types of like crash jokes we
did before and it's actually worse now
another woman feels even more otherwise
because like oh my God why do you talk
like this I think that internet
communities especially online ones that
do like political debate and video games
are very much like big boys clubs so
it's not enough to just say you can't be
misogynistic to get rid of misogyny
there's always going to be an othering
effect on women there's a lot of like
behaviors that are unintuitive that you
have to account for and you've got to
try to like push that back and that's
just a very very challenging thing to do
um so like I I like to deal with
concrete examples more so here's a
concrete example and this is like a
recent initiative in my community
because I'm trying to like be because
misogyny hasn't been fixed anywhere on
the internet and I'm curious well there
are ways that I can push my community to
do this
um I don't think you should almost ever
make a comment on a woman's appearance
ever if they're appearing in like some
political or professional manner even if
it's a positive comment I think it's
equally bad to a negative comment it's
just never good to do and that's kind of
an unintuitive thing because it's like
well a woman appears wow she's really
cute it seems like a nice comment you're
being nice you know she looks cute
whatever but it's like it's not at all
the point of why she's there and just by
saying that you're kind of like
authorizing her as like a person to like
think she looks good rather than
listening to anything she has to say you
know well there's a lot of stuff that
you're saying and
that is a part of massaging it's almost
like obvious like any woman will tell
you that woman well yeah but they're not
in these spaces and a lot of the guys
don't know I think what that requires
is just empathy
you don't need you don't need you need
to consider the female experience
that's it like you have to either read
about or talk with women you learn like
the low-hanging food is very easy to
learn it feels like just the level of
social skill
oftentimes in Internet communities is
quite low I.E disagree I don't like to
say here's the problem with empathy is
it's very hard to have empathy for
experiences that are so outside of your
own it well maybe some people there
might be some people that can do it I
can't there's a lot of stuff that I had
to learn women are half the population
but they're women
they're totally different
they're totally different okay so here's
what we talk about yeah yeah so this is
not totally totally so here's an example
Okay so
especially for me my archetype makes up
a lot of the internet white man
um there's never been a point the name
of a beautiful woman who it might be a
dancer what's the backstory from New
Orleans or from I haven't thought that
through yet all right um yeah it's
ambiguous okay like an open world open
world I want you to project whatever
wherever you want Destiny the dancer to
be from that's in your mind okay all
right I'll save that for later tonight
yeah okay
as a white guy there I don't know if
there's ever been a spot that I've been
in where I've made been made to feel
like I don't belong there just by virtue
of who I am I don't I actually don't I
it's impossible for me to empathize that
because I don't even have that
experience if you go back eight nine
years one of the big issues that came up
was harassment and gaming against women
and I was one of the big Debaters
against that saying that like sure women
might get harassment but everybody gets
harassment if you're a woman and you're
in gaming and you get harassed
congratulations you're being treated
like a man what you're actually asking
for is for us to actually treat you
differently you don't want to be
insulted you don't want to be treated
like a man and that's actually a
misogyny is women making that argument
you still stand by that is that a
problem if I do
no I'm just kidding well okay hold on a
little it's a little while I disagree
with it sure okay that's good you should
a little while later
um I had a friend uh Jessica super cool
girl we go to play games she was between
jobs and she's like I've got like two
months and we're gonna grind CS go and
I'm like okay this is awesome let's do
it uh CS go um Counter-Strike Global
Offensive shooter game FPS microphones
first day we start playing okay hop into
our first game obviously she talks
everybody's making is that a 12 year old
boy why aren't you making sandwiches
blah blah blah yeah okay whatever player
first game play our second game same
jokes third game fourth game by like the
fourth or fifth game I was actually
starting to feel triggered like every
time the game started I was like can you
just like talk so we can get over like
the stupid [ __ ] jokes it's so [ __ ]
stupid and you hear the same [ __ ]
joke every single time and it took one
day of that experience for me to realize
it's not about being insulted it's like
this othering feeling that you don't
belong and I've never felt that because
I'm a white guy like it's not to be like
virtually similar so but like there's
just there's no places where it's like
you're white you don't belong here
you're guy you don't belong here like
I've never felt that not inclusion and
playing with her there's a different
feeling when it's the same types of
jokes coming from a group of people to
make you feel like you don't belong
there where I was like damn this
actually feels really bad and it feels
bad in a different way where it's like
if you call me
um like NF slur or any other type of
swear word or insult like yeah you can
call me that but at the end of the day
like we're all kind of the same we're
all white dudes and we call each other
names but like this is a woman and this
is not her place and she doesn't belong
here
kind of the analogy that I would make
because I after getting these
experiences I've learned this afterwards
if I tell you that there's another guy
in a room and you need to think of the
worst insults ever for that person
without ever knowing anything about them
or meeting them if I tell you that it's
like a white straight guy and you have
to write insults you're [ __ ] maybe you
can do like school shooter there's not
really much you can say at the end of
the day but if I tell you it's a woman
we could there are so many different
jokes you can write if it's a black
person so many different races things we
can say are you sure I can come up with
a lot of stuff for a white guy in terms
of stuff that is just intrinsic to him
being a white guy yeah like there's
really wait a minute what are you
talking about there's a lot the internet
has sharpened that sword in terms of
like jokes that are targeted at his sex
and yourself virgin
weak some of the Ansel version maybe
yeah that's getting there sure that's
for sure
um that's recent though sorry I'm older
on the internet we didn't have those
words way back then when I was making
these analogies that installing version
my day we didn't have generally there
were no installs back then none of us
had sex we just accepted we were all
computer Gamers nobody had sex to play
video games back then okay people don't
remember that there wasn't the Big Bang
Theory you were just a loser that was
stuck you guys didn't even know sex
exists we had to download sexual
pictures and they took two minutes and
you didn't even know if you were gonna
get the right thing by the time it
finished loading but what I'm saying is
that like okay so you think you agree
that like if somebody gives you like a
race like a black person who's a woman
we can write like very cutting scathing
like insults for that person that are
very authorizing oh words that would
really hurt yeah that are very cutting
to the person but like for a White Guy
um it's kind of hard because it's like
that's like the default there's not as
much other rising of those people yeah
so that's kind of the insults you have
from white guy the white guy the insults
are much harsher so when you start to
apply the same kind of harshness to
other groups you can make them feel like
they really don't belong and that other
Rising effect is something that's very
hard for me I can't really empathize
like I've never felt it so I have to
intellectualize it and then sympathize
with it it's like a whole process I have
to go through and then I try to walk
other people through that because if
you're a white guy on the internet which
is a lot of the internet you really
don't know what that feels like you've
never felt like that before yes so
you're now in a leadership position uh
Grandpa Destiny so that's a lot of
people look up to you for that for that
sort of Pathway to empathy yeah
not to uh otherwise I mean you have felt
other eyes in you you mentioned High
School people like not being
yeah but those were always for things
that like it's different to insult
somebody for a non-immutable
characteristic like okay you think
poorly about me because I'm like not
enough money or I don't have money but I
could get more money and I could change
that but it's different for somebody to
really attack you for like your gender
or attack you for like your race a lot
of the attacks that hit the hardest is
not about gender
it's
it's I do think that they're like the
way women are attacked on the internet
it's the same kind of attacks you would
do towards other guys but you go harsher
I feel like they're fundamentally
different I feel like when we're
attacking guys I'm not usually attacking
you on like
the virtue of you being a guy but like
if it's a woman and she's typing
something like oh did your boyfriend
type that for you or like what are you
even doing here like don't you shouldn't
you be trying to find a husband or like
oh you're like a stupid kind of like
ghost Titan only fans or no but the
stupidity the intelligence aspect is
what's attacked yeah but it's so much
different like you can call a guy stupid
but that's because he's a guy that's
being stupid but when you call a woman
stupid she's stupid because she's a
woman yeah but I honestly think that
women are called stupid more than men on
the internet but I've got nothing to do
like the attack is not gendered it's the
gender inspires an increased level of
attack I feel like it is gendered I wish
we had data on this have you ever heard
of the xkcd Comics yes it's a really
good comic wear and I this is something
that I've dealt with a lot in my
community okay there's a guy at a board
and he [ __ ] up a math equation and it's
like wow you suck at math and then the
next panel is there's a girl that does
it and she [ __ ] it up and it's like wow
women stuck at math and there's like
that feeling that happens where when I
bring on
um I want usernames but they're like
YouTube people that I've run on that
have crazy opinions and when they're men
that person is crazy oh my God he said
the crazy stuff he's so dumb he's so
crazy so stupid but when it's a woman
it's like oh my God why do you always
bring dumb women here why do so many
women on the internet have crazy
opinions there's a different like
minority character that has to like
stand it and like represent like their
whole group where like white men don't
typically have to speaking of groups
versus individuals yes but then what I
feel happens is then another person from
that group comes another woman comes and
people before she says anything
will already feel like they're ready
with that attack for sure but they're
ready for the attack she's a woman
they're gonna call her she's stupid
because she's not because she said
something anymore just because she's a
woman
so like uh the group
in their brain accumulates all the
negative characteristics of the
individuals they've met not the positive
the negative and it becomes like this
ball of stickiness and then that becomes
the bias for their judgment of a new
person that comes with white men there's
more of a blank slate in terms of bias
of how they analyze the person with any
any of the minority group they're
basically make a judgment
based on the negative characteristics of
the individuals they met in the past I
just that leads to a system where you're
just harsher towards minority groups and
towards women how do you solve that the
first the most important thing for any
problem ever is step one is to be aware
of it if you're not aware of it then
you're hopelessly lost at sea but yeah
the first thing I like to say is just
like be aware of it like I've had
there's a girl that I've had on recently
and she says a lot of in my opinion kind
of crazy things but people will use her
as like this is why women shouldn't be
here this is like she's crazy and she's
a woman and blah blah blah but I can
bring on a guy who's similarly dumb
things and he's evaluated on his own
merits because it's a guy you know
there's never ever ever been a case
where I brought a stupid guy on stream
and everybody's like this guy makes me
hate men this guy makes me hate white
people that has never happened but then
there's like other women that come on
and it's like now I know why installs
exist or I totally understand where red
pill ideology comes from you know and
even if the statements are kind of true
when you're making these observations
over and over and over and over again it
it damages your ability to individually
perceive somebody and then two people
that make the same statements one can be
be perceived more harshly just because
of that like group bias you've got built
up I think there's something about
streaming that just brings that out of
people like because you have to talk for
like seven hours so you're like all
right well whatever psychological issues
and complexities I I have I'm going to
explore that it's magnified magnified
and then we'll and then it's the drawers
you talked about the memetic uh uh
Theory so gerardian like whatever
the things that are very similar and
you're going to magnify the conflicts
that you have and you're going to
explore the all the different
perspectives on those different
conflicts and I mean I don't I don't
know if it's just anecdotal but it's
nice to have women on stream and I think
the dynamic uh that you guys have is is
wonderful it's really interesting so
yeah it's just a female voice in general
I love having women on the podcast the
female voice I feel like is under heard
on the internet for sure and I would
love the internet to be a place where
women feel safe to speak